rely I'm live we might start cutting out
the beginning of these as I do nothing
here in the first few minutes but let
your presence be known people who are
the first people to say hello
talking waiting people doing these
impromptu live streams and they just to
just wait around
we got one eye on us yeah one who's the
one I hear Chester John's - John's the
big new what an interesting name here
alright just gonna wait for a few more
faces to show up and then we're good to
go
how are you guys doing today everyone's
gone already now already left can you
guys hear us hey Brian this could be
very meditative I could just see who
shows up okay oh we got a chat wow
people are chiming in
hi Amy Amy say hi to John you know
that's who you really want to say hi to
John's are cool hey Eddie Brian Brian
Brian
[Music]
all right guys since you can hear us now
thank you Mike that's so sweet you're
awesome you're the awesome one you son
of a [ __ ] you've not seen parasite yet
Amy says John is looking extra fine
today time to do some movie news people
you know how this goes you guys drive
the movie news for us we're just gonna
take the topics that you guys are
talking about
then we're gonna stroll it I'm John
Campea this is Robert Maya Burnett I'm
Kristin harloff this is Mark Ellis Rob
servation
yes running at a PBS Christian library
number on this so guys before we go into
that as tradition established we must do
the next dope trope if you guys are no
dope trope is this is the thing of when
things happen in movies that
is cliches but are not talked about and
that I have registered as official
cliches and John has started
contributing to these as well this dope
trope you might have seen it in the
season eight of Game of Thrones or many
a battlefield movies this is when
characters are on the battlefield of
wars happening whatever usually it's
with swords blades and then it's like
let's say John and I are fighting like
oh we're that's like oh we're fine but
we celebrated too early and then one of
us gets like our head chopped off or
stabbed in the chest they celebrated way
too early if you've seen Game of Thrones
Season eight you know which scene I'm
referring to but I see it in every
almost every war movie what you get for
having a human moment on a battle well
you're like huh we're all right and
forget the rest of them too soon you
guys know what I'm talking about
yeah all right John since I'm usually
being like John go to get the questions
go get it Oh hominin you hold this I'm
gonna find a question for us we're gonna
mix it up you're the judgment we're
gonna mix it up I'm the tripod guy I'm
gonna guilt the phone all day Robert
Pattinson is training for the Batman
he's probably well trained for the bat
me he's probably done training for the
Batman to be honest spider-verse - what
about it possible they didn't announce
that spider-verse - okay here's my issue
with spider-verse - too many spider-man
why is the directors who won the Oscar
not returning for this role excited that
it's Lord and Miller producing right and
then everyone seems to think that into
the spider-verse was strictly fair movie
for some reason when they produced it
there was a co-writing a story credit on
by one of them co-wrote it but the movie
was helmed by three different
individuals whose names I don't even
remember but I know they're I don't
remember their names unfortunately but I
know it's not Lordan
exactly I know enough to know that I
feel like if you win the Oscar you your
work to get back the main people who
helped helm that movie right yes usually
the way things should go unless they
wanted to move on that does seem like an
odd choice to completely change your
writing and directing team you know yeah
I mean in a sense I don't know what
three people do to direct an animated
film like that seems like a type of
medium you'd want several hands on
because there are a lot of things to
think about but I mean like one writer
one director could be interesting but
also yeah it's weird it's strange it's
strange all right John don't worry I'll
be right back oh yes another one
Oh question day here and entertain I'm
gonna get us another question don't
sleep at Dragon Ball Z I had no idea of
that gene Jeter I saw your name but I
didn't see what you said does this mean
Dragon Ball Z will cross over into MC
MCU or star wars oh my god Lynnae 1a oh
my god Lynnae give us a question would
you you're so sweet to do that oh my god
little nay the the costume she was gonna
spend on getting a sexy wrestling outfit
for Halloween she has now contributed to
the super chat here dude what we need to
dress like sexy right only want people
who are already pledged to the patreon
page who are ready contributing their
hard-earned dollars for a patreon to
contribute to this super yes only only
then nobody else though I'm like you
guys already contributing contributing
more as YouTube becomes weirder you guys
are directly funding the free
combination here to sweet thang thank
you and to sweet she introduces to
rapper n F NSF nerve football NSA the
NSA and the National Security organism
Oh Ant Man 3 and man 3 excited about Ant
Man 3 John water your thoughts Robert
Myer Bernette oh my Rob servation ZAR
that this is gonna I'm happily surprised
that they're gonna do an ant-man 3 I
think it's smart to play in the mid
range and maybe cultivate that area more
I mean I'm at this point
just happy that he didn't get the axe
honestly I mean it seems like ant-man is
important for the MC moving forward in
some way shape or form and I think the
comedy the direct comedy of ant-man is a
good flavor to keep alive within the MCU
so yeah but John those films are
failures they don't make a billion
dollar I know what's the point what's
the point and they're not heavy like all
the rest of them see you films that are
all dramatic and heavy I just don't see
the point in making it if it's not gonna
make us be billing you know dollars
least a trillion not billion sincerely
speaking and I do think that ant-man 3 I
you know people put a lot of weight on
trilogies as if it's like in this day
and age I'd say they should have stopped
Terminator 2 in this day and age I would
say that yeah you gotta make your three
but odds are threes are usually not that
great I personally like ant-man in the
wasp more than ant-man
or one I don't it's it's like what
really how cute that fresh was enhancing
more of the character journey beyond
Scott Lang hanging out with the other
characters in a lot of ways Scott Lang
was kind of like the Mad Max of his own
franchise about the pins and then
there's Scott Lee yeah just kind of know
were involved in their legacy and
dealing with their fallout I guess I
would like to see more of him really
take the lead this time around that
would be nice you had to see a Scott
Lang movie or something that's very
centered on him where he is integral not
just involved John I'll be right back
Gayla gonna get another question love
let's do this you gotta fill the silence
oh I'm sorry
hey guys so Pokemon movie directed by
Quentin Tarantino I think that's a great
great idea I think the world lends
itself and I really want to see you know
basically what kind of you know gritty
violent animal combat is gonna take
place you know especially that Tarantino
dialogue filtered through Pokemon who
can only say their own names like that
would be pretty sick I think for V
Ferrari
any thoughts here's my thought all of
our friends are on the Disney press
screening list which is us - for some
reason we weren't invited no those are
my thoughts screening this Wednesday and
we didn't get that we got Maleficent
you know that's great we love that movie
great favorite of the year
I'm excited before viewed Ferrari though
I mean you know um I like that James
Mangold and all the people in it okay
okay looks like rush that I actually
want to see Jon's
yes Halloween kills mm-hmm Halloween
whatever ends yes what do you think the
future of the franchise will be John I
throw this to you uh what do you think
it will be I'm gonna slip in my wish
list right now and I think that the more
this whole we're doing the direct sequel
thing to the only one specific
installment is the the bigger that gets
in the more times that fails I think
we're going to get to a point where
Studios are gonna say whatever let's
just make sequels to any of the sequels
so I want the future of the Halloween
franchise to be a sequel that's part
three
just take it in a completely different
direction like the thing is as much as
Halloween 2019 successfully did the
whole we're ignoring all the sequels
thing even though it wasn't like amazing
yeah he's good at the same time I'm very
wary about a new trilogy cuz I'm still
like where is this trilogy gonna go
that's not another version of very
immediate we gotta evade and kill
Michael Myers but we're not gonna until
part three at the very weak
like you know sure I think we should
start you know the way how we're going
forget those sequels we're gonna be
picking it up from here we should be
doing like we got started like weird
numbers like I hope Chris Rock saw
ignores yes exactly saw five six and
seven and then a seven furious only
acknowledges two four and seven and the
rest are not saying we gotta yeah we got
it like okay well I brie odd number fast
and furious movie should be ignored or
like em but with the continuity even
once or now every time a slasher
franchise tried to switch through it up
with like a new killer like like Friday
the 13th part five make a sequel of that
one where it's still kind of Jason but
not Jason another scream movie reboot
was announced of course it was and
they're gonna do this forever
and some of them are gonna be ok and
some of them are noon and not me is it
gonna star a female it no it might like
the other stream movies because I'm not
down for this woke [ __ ] now see here's
what they're gonna do to make the Randy
character a girl so the expert who's
constantly spouting off the Ruby stuff
is a girl and she is then going to also
make meta commentary on the fact that
these types of characters being replaced
with girls
thus you know furthering the meninist
the whole franchise adding feminist met
inist to the works
the rules are breaking this is pretty
soon it's gonna be a free-for-all and
you can make a sequel to anything you
want don't know what they could I mean I
think you can scream is one of those
frat I don't think you can keep the
Sidney Prescott thing going but I do
think you can explore some other type of
commentary you could have it exists
within the scream world kind of like
Jumanji when they acknowledge Allen or
Robin Williams character with one
sentence just do that it's like that
Prescott thing well and also I think
scream is in it is in a weird place
because the slasher is not the thing
anymore as much as it used to be it's a
niche again so I feel like maybe
could benefit from growing beyond
typical slasher movie commentary and
vote for more broad psychological
commentary honor
Michael B thank you so much buddy me
getting media another alien three with
Sigourney returning yeah baby one
wanting that forever Neill Blomkamp make
it happen we've been wanting them yet
see how one would excite me
damn aside me and that was the one that
kicked this conversation off I think it
was even before Halloween got made was
they're like oh we're gonna ignore we're
gonna go back to aliens and finish it
there they should just de-age Sigourney
Weaver yeah why good teenage you
microbeads are actors
you know every watch I brought this up
to you a while ago I rewatched Godfather
to just yesterday we're gonna try to
catch the Irishman on the weekend um
rewatch Godfather to and that was the
first movie that have Pacino and De Niro
in the same movie but you know they
don't cross paths because of two
different time periods and then it's
cutting back and forth right and it made
me go wow if they made this today they
would have just D H Marlon Brando and we
wouldn't have gotten that oscar-winning
performance from Robert De Niro that a
literal oscar-winning performance but
they would have just D aged Brando
that's exactly does that funny yeah
actually
and I mean the narrows the aging
Terminator where there's a completely
CGI Diaz - Eddie furlong and linda ham
with like yes yeah you really don't need
to cast anymore I don't want to John
I'm swinging back and do it let's jump
in there I'm just gonna keep the people
entertaining to trains have you seen
that meme it's a great gladiator meme a
plus but me you bring back new they
could bring Riley in three four alien
three the Blomkamp cut released the
Schneider Blomkamp cut HBO max news more
streaming we're gonna get cable online
pretty soon okay okay so which horror
classic light shining deserves a sequel
come on John horror classic like The
Shining that deserves a sequel well come
on
what like Rosemary's Baby or something
yeah baby should be all grown up yeah
I'm just a demon you know living in
where do they live in the movie in the
New York City like this what's that show
or Lucifer know the god the damn show on
freaking the the [ __ ] Michael Sheen
killgrave oh good oh good Oh me yeah
yeah yeah demon boy yeah make you kind
of light you know give it some Missy cuz
that Rosemary's Baby there's one thing
it was missing it was some levity yeah
but it just get Roman Polanski to yes
that's what we need he's the only one
who can do it
but I don't know you know what the if
they do another like baby is Satan movie
they should make it a girl that's the
gender flip by bo Kaitlyn because we
don't get that you always get little
boys make it a teenage boy who gets
possessed by the demon but yes the demon
baby is a girl I think that's a good oh
my god annoying rancer awesome
contributed to the super chat
sup big fan crazy ID thank you you are
helping Collider movie talks stay alive
I appreciate it
he says sup big fan crazy idea for a am
3 MN 3 Ant Man 3 since paper that are
you saying it's 3:00 in the morning
yeah pretty excited cos it's 3 a.m. and
I don't sleep since P read wants to chew
f4 wow you are really into the
abbreviations here Fantastic Four yes
housing without ensuring ok them here as
scientists trapped in the quantum realm
then get woken up after being trapped
here since the 60s
basically quantum realm is the MCU naked
neck zone mega zone [ __ ] own right
that that actually would work if they
can feed her out away I'll be down I
mean this idea I I have the
you know angry annoying rancher you
bring up a good point yeah III think
that with everything they're doing with
introducing quantum realm and now it
looks like that with this next phase
there's gonna be a lot of focus on
multiverses opening of these things
really helps with making it easier to
push x-men and Fantastic Four in there I
really actually like your idea that way
you could do a movie of Fantastic Four
in an earlier decade and then justify
how they could be in the present day
movies as well like with Captain America
it took place in medieval times and then
he was frozen for a thousand years and
then woke up in 1984 which how we got
Avengers Assemble movie trivia knowledge
right there John what do you think of
the Annoying ranters idea I think it's a
great idea I think that I can i when you
read the comment all I could see in here
in my brain was a post-credits ting of
like Scott Lang hearing some kind of
weird chatter on a radio trying to make
out whatever the voice is saying and
then it's something like Richards
Richard and then the Reed Richards who's
that and then we smashed a black and
then you know he's gotta go in the
quantum zone and find the Reed Richards
and then we from yet oh I can totally
see it I can hear it you know I like it
you know hey what thoughts on the
Godfather remake announcer director Todd
Phillips that's [ __ ] I don't know
what Twitter News you're reading Michael
that ain't true oh my thoughts is that's
a funny joke lynnae's asking have you
all ever thought about going paranormal
investigating him so count me in funny
enough Calver honor who was just on this
channel sent me a text asking if we ship
we could like do a thing where we have
hidden cameras to go paranormal
investigators say at a haunted place and
I said yes
because that means sexual stuff with
John Callie's gonna go down that's why
we do this whole channel to get John
some I'm just I'm telling you we make a
living off of this arrangement
it's crazy are
okay any thoughts about carnage in venom
- guys I'm sorry there's so many
questions I kind of just see what's
there and then I ask it
carnage of venom - do we have thoughts
really what we should do is just answer
if we have thoughts does that mean we
have to say we have thoughts you know
say what the thoughts are I barely have
a thought I remember hearing people have
strong opinions at a time and noting
those thoughts my thoughts are really
just other people's thoughts don't
really like the idea of Woody
Harrelson's carving he just doesn't have
the energy but I like woody so I do like
wood really if Ruben Fleischer was
returning I might have been excited
because him they seem to work really
well - yeah and he's clearly Woody's
having a great time and zombie brings
out a great part of woody insomnia Oh
Britney Lange Britney Lane Scott leg
just want to say hi to you guys and how
are things going any thoughts in the
next matrix yeah I hope in the first ten
minutes they kill off neo and then the
new cast members are the new ones and
they should call it the matrix rebooted
and at one point before the end of the
movie neo toss is like a flash drive to
one of the new many catches it and
that's the symbol to show that they're
carrying on the matrix mm-hmm at least
until it doesn't make money and then we
rebooted again later down the line Thank
You Carter Lovejoy for for your
contribution here cat needs cats needs
to top endgame in Star Wars I agree I
hope we are so wrong about that ie is so
ho cuz right now it just seems like the
worst movie of year and I am hoping that
by the time it comes out of rooms like
seems like a train wreck a crime that
makes some money though yeah it's like I
either want it to make a huge amount of
money or be surprisingly good or both oh
you know if we're gonna start yeah I
Kurt you Lovejoy you got a great point
you know if we're gonna start redoing
you know male characters and
off the females we gotta start redoing
female characters yeah like the male
let's get a male Romy and Michele let's
get a male clueless let's get a male
ocean's 8 let's let's get a reboot dude
this is a call again also classic horror
sequel finally figured it out
I want a sequel to freaks we do comedy
some guys young Jerry I'm diving back
into the questions right now can I get a
good one gee we ain't got all dia de los
muertos sorry you had a question about
the short film I was in which by the way
is up trust me I noticed there were
supposed to be a time jump there that
wasn't made clear in the Edit it was one
of my one of my two producers notes see
it was and then I was like oh this is
done guys you gotta change
oh okay but I appreciate you taking the
time of watching there's another
follow-up short film coming I will be
promoting it more this week on the
channel just as little heads up going
back into the questions
Carter Lovejoy a female Cornetto trilogy
out if Edgar Wright and Simon Pegg inand
their crew wanted to do some kind of
female centric series of films that way
just like pick some awesome female
comics who they work with that would be
someone said male sex in the city I love
it I would love it and I would love it
and then they saw so dead Chara of the
dead I would watch it guys these gender
flips are great yeah I I'm loving them
yes always alito battle DiMeo Kill Bill
kill what's your favorite movie this
year it says new Japan hi
lights favorite movie this year uh Joker
and game lighthouse movies uh in every
Tarantino movies the best it's still
onion it's still a game my girlfriend's
gonna kill me she's all about that Joker
which by the way we're talking about
that it might be the first r-rated movie
to make a billion dollars which that
would be cool for r-rated movies it
would be a completely original r-rated
movie not based on any anti thing yeah
III know it wouldn't be cool I guess for
a movie that's basically an actual film
but that is also got comic book skins
all over that's like this is what we
need now to make these kinds of films
profit I'm pretty sure there are some
other r-rated films though that if
adjusted for inflation would be I think
Terminator 2 would actually be up there
I think probably especially if you count
the amount of times that's been
re-examining I'm sure yeah I was the
question
cash on the Christ baby or Matrix
Reloaded guys adjust things for
inflation a Britney you're so sweet what
movies are you look while you think of
that John I'm gonna answer Britney's
question what movies are you looking
forward to seeing next year I got one
answer for you and Sir John's answer to
my lens okay get ready it's not black
widow which by the way that should
reboot with a guy yeah or Wonder Woman
1984 also guy reboot Oso guy revealed
Wonderman Wonderman Wonderman and
superwoman and it's gonna be Chris Rock
Saw movie because we are saw fans we do
this better or I saw you got you go
check that out we're definitely saw fans
and even though we know how bad a lot
mark it's just a so strange it's just a
weird mix so weird combo I I'm waiting
for that trailer that will definitely
not be monetized as a company but I'm
waiting to cover that trailer so
that's the most anticipated like
everything about that movie I'd is like
cats but in the right way where I'm like
I don't know what this combinations
gonna produce no idea yeah I just want
like all the Sam Jackson in jigsaws
world guys I'm diving back into the
question dive back in died oh my
favorite movies I just saw Jojo rabbit
which I thought was terrific so I need
to sit that in my noggin but uh for
whatever reason when asked this question
rocket man's always what comes to mind
really really enjoy I just want to say
before we go to the next question
keep these gender swaps coming on
Reservoir Dublin's already got some like
I wants to female Reservoir Dogs that's
what we're talking about Disney's and
glorious bastards I'd come into a Disney
Plus limited series near you I mean
they've already gone on the Netflix yes
I'm gonna I think record one next week
well would we love another Friday the
13th film there was a very short live
segment that took up a lot of time to do
that was a labor of love
start office cosplay this is so feature
just because it took a lot of work Greg
and John's fan fiction and it's um but
essentially the concept was how it could
work so we would take these ideas and
franchise based properties and go here's
how we would do it in fact I haven't
returned your dark faints mother review
I was like there's something there that
I thought that could have been the great
follow-up sequel if they just focus on
this one thing but moves live it out for
three days and it's killing it the Pope
it's right now don't wanna spoil it but
for Friday the 13th the first one we did
for how it could work was he came up
with a like it is a full pitch it's not
it's like full outline spend a week
cooking it up and and then we just kind
of pitch it to the camera and it was our
idea of how we would reboot a Friday the
13th and it was very pilot like really a
really positive response and I was like
surprised by like wow people really
loved our pitch and it was it's like a
15 to 20 minute video
yeah yeah it's very easy one walkthrough
of the plug yeah
so I forgot I forgot some of the details
but yeah like another Friday 13th why
not down in one
I think if I'm not mistaken they would
be the 13th film there are certain
franchises where I don't care how I feel
like for a Friday the 13th I'm
personally of the mind make just another
sequel but to space them that much
further out so that like every 7 to 10
years we get one and then you know it'll
be fun because we already have 12 make
Jason a girl bring back Pam reboot the
franchise sequel directly to the first
movie where Pamela Voorhees doesn't die
and continues on in her so let's do this
let's do this Billa and Tita male
Matilda male tilde mister dude fire the
running woman the running woman yes
Halloween with Michelle Myers
oh man oh man longer than burger these
are great Frankie Krueger yeah Disney
Princess unite nice Ted I can't get over
that black man widow Oh Joan and silent
boob so something that John I tend to
deal with like nicknaming people which a
lot of people do is we just just kind of
rhymed in her names with something and
Andrew Gorgon we went to go see
Terminator with him Hellraiser is
already pretty female and his dad's name
is burl
sweatshirt and I was like Earl curse of
the Black Pearl it was like you know in
context no no
female daddy so mommy's home they should
reboot daddy's home but just call it
daddy's home with it but you woman and
then just have them all make who's your
daddy jokes ad nauseum throughout the
entire film male hocus pocus hocus pocus
hocus pocus trope forever genders
Goodfellas reboot good ladies good good
war war [ __ ] terrible but great
lesbian Fifty Shades I'll give you a
half a point for that one oh this is so
good this is my favorite live stream
ever done
female wouldn't it be bad girls bad bad
ladies bad [ __ ] that's what our
grammar school a bad boys bad [ __ ]
inventory's keep them coming this is
this is a chance to keep your treat of
juices goddess Zilla I love it
I appreciate that Omni what happened
when they need a star she got pregnant
she's she's mad pregnant she's carrying
a clone baby triplets mm-hmm three
clones and what's supposed to be a
secret yeah so stepsisters who would
that it would star rebel Wilson and
Melissa McCarthy
okay mr. Doubtfire Queen Kong yeah I
mean the roland emmerich Godzilla
Godzilla was a lady
so John wig for thoughts good eye
I am generally excited over the concept
of continuing to live in the John wick
averse I would like a break because I'm
afraid of the point at which these are
going to become a little too much a
little too quickly and they're gonna
start diminishing I think they've had a
great amount of luck with the three that
they've made I still love the first one
the most and
the bigger you get there's just more to
balance so while I'm always down for
kick-ass Keanu action I would like maybe
a little brake pump to take some time
hear me out
yeah you get Tom need you John wick for
and then you get John like a five and
you get Tom Cruise to be the main baddie
in it
wicked impossible oh and then they get
them both to like fly a fighter jet and
jump out of it like real time parachute
out you know land in a river get swept
up accept counter is really good at
crediting his stunt double he is really
good at doing and telling you when
exactly that guy is doing his yeah he's
not mine breaking the illusion for us
we're watching no but Tom Cruise he
would have to do his own stunts
Ramba yeah we're all this ruthless SOI
boys now oh my god if they can really
really do like a completely authentic
Rambo movie but the just stars a female
Rambo and it's still just bloody and
like that would be awesome I wasn't
personally a fan of the way John wick
three ended like I'm talking its final
few minutes I was Lydia I I did not like
of how it ended where Whedon in order
for this story to finish we need to
watch the next one I thought it would
have been more effective if they could
if they ended it in a way where we could
have a sequel but it could end here if
we wanted it to John works for me
doesn't end that way John wave three
ends in a way of nope no we need the
four yeah and it's like John week one
ends that way like it could end here if
we wanted it to john-boy - I was okay
with the cliffhanger there cuz I'm like
yeah a trilogy but yeah you know it's
like a fourth it's hard to get a third
one where John week three is a rare case
of knocking it out with a third one yeah
um so John would fly I'm low worries I'm
like down man could they really do it
toi sorry for pulling it off
with Keanu with Keanu but that's yeah I
feel like john-john I was led to believe
that the third one would have some kind
of finality to it and this is what I'm
becoming a weary of in Hollywood is when
people are like no no we're gonna do
justice we're gonna end this thing here
or we're gonna go back and we're gonna
do honor to such and such a thing of the
past and then you frequently now find
that it's not exactly what they've led
you to believe and I'm not saying that
that's on like Chad's to hell skier the
creators necessarily although I'm sure
they want to continue but it did feel
like one of those things where it's like
no no we gotta make it clear this
franchise gonna keep going and John wick
story is not over and yeah I wasn't in
love with the very end Terpening says
new life interpreting says Chelsea's
angels or Devils Oh
Chelsea's Devils ooh you could even keep
it as Charlie I mean like their chicks
named Charlie you could even morning
Devils yeah we wouldn't cast suave
Channing Tatum type guys who are like
action sexy not just gross blanket on so
many names today the guy who rebooted
Halloween diner
oh did Danny McBride Danny McBride
female real rejects I'm sure that
channel exists in some fashion married
thanks Dolan jew-fro cool fro Dylan I
hope you got my my voice mail Jason I
left you a voicemail female 8 mile yeah
about Iggy Azalea or another female
white rampage to remake Jaws but with a
make laDawn
oh yes and maybe instead every time
you're like we need people to go to the
beach we got tourists we all get the
money of the tourists
and the public beach and the public is
like ain't no sarcana get me to wake my
Beach the only [ __ ] I'm for this why I
can go Jim okay go anywhere else in this
world or you know prioritize our own
safety female e Andrassy I that's what I
want to is let's do some historical
reckon I want a female Freddie Mercury
just because even if it's not true
thoughts on Han getting justice in the
future in Jurassic Park poet commands
gendered eyes not laughing at trim what
don't get the con don't they already
have in Jurassic Park dinosaurs who can
switch their genders though didn't they
oh yeah so it's already happening they
gotta do a close-up on it though yes yes
of course they gotta show it
Oh thoughts on Han getting justice in a
future of fast and furious movie here's
my thoughts oh I stopped caring about
equal but only to Tokyo Drift okay seven
with seven yeah
the only for those 2 starring Han oh my
god Lana from Hawaii's back your real
the real Lana she's real guys justice
for Han I you know what I like Han I'm
with you I'm just to be devil's advocate
in the in the lowest low-key way
possible I hope so I also marvel
yeah Marvel is marshals I also hope that
eventually once the the hype and
everything dies down for these new Star
Wars films we can get the true sequel to
the force awakens that retcons Han
Solo's death so he doesn't die there you
go like I love it just equal directly
love what you're saying so only the
force awake
Mayo Mean Girls that would be just your
average bully just dude yeah it's just a
boy yeah my school yeah you know maybe
not today I feel like high school I mean
they're still bullying that happy a
little different a lot of it would take
place off-camera in like you know little
phone blurbs and stuff John we need to
be closer to the Internet box you could
you go oh male legally blonde i season
the Spartacus right now I took a break
because there's air
there's Watchmen haven't seen their
episode of Watchmen yet female Spartacus
we should do rivets up true stories
female its gender swap social network is
the male Mean Girls Erin Brockovich but
with an a a a a run yes oh yeah all
right oh and then do what's another
Steve Jobs dude likes TV jobs
Stephanie job oh my god that would be
because one of them is gonna be at least
very interesting yeah like who you're
taking the true story and so weird
somebody said male FORSCOM female
Lincoln I don't think I think uh he
watched the movie correctly I you should
go back and re-examine that Forrest is
the Tom Hanks character
female duck tails and male Hannah
Montana I'm looking forward to the dude
movie not because I'm a fan of the book
or the original film but because it is
Dennis vagina do the movies I'm so
excited
yeah brother of Eurovision the
commentary Vince McMahon jobs that's the
most weird combination yet no it's not
even a gender bender dick tails nice
female the stars born they should know
50 makeup stars for you lady gaga with
the window down just want to get one
last look at you okay usual suspects but
with chicks people still call them
chicks usual suspects with rods yeah hot
date with Dame's dude hot rod remake hot
broad there you go there you go
terminologies oh man this video has five
likes we're killing it right now it's
just the phone super delayed female
laura-leigh got a lot of
female taxi driver female Joker female
Joker yeah they call like Harley corners
nope yeah it seemed the V team oh that's
not bad
this should be the jumping-off point for
all of our male hustlers is Magic Mike
Harley does not condone chicks
terminology that's true you know what's
hard for me about I was talking with the
Delia Chamberlain a patron about this
it's challenging to me to only view
Harley Quinn as Harley Quinn without the
Joker when it seems like so many from
comics this new animated show that on DC
Universe I think is what it is
even the birds of prey trailer know some
Netflix it's all going here you in the
birds of prey trailer yeah it's it's
always like Harley Quinn saying I'm my
own person I don't need mr. J focus on
you're trying to separate yourself from
my main hope is that birds of prey can
be a success of the next Harley Quinn
movie we don't have to worry about the
Joker yeah it'd be really nice to get
away from the Joker for a minute show
boys that is with that's called Magic
Man it's also magic that yeah male birds
of prey that's suicide squads John
Connor but as a female with little
development someone saw her return save
in the future
walk the feline no no I love it
Jared Leto is back oh my gosh these are
so good okay okay well that's a real
question change eater thing and we're
gonna go back to the okay what are you
most looking forward to a Disney Plus um
everything I'm genuinely like so excited
for guys I'm like I cannot wait for this
service to launch Lana I is this service
just like the new shows yes I'm excited
be I guess why what excites me about the
shows they're launching is how like in
terms of interconnectivity of how
they're connected to the bigger picture
they're connected to the bigger movies
you know what I mean yeah like the
Marvel Netflix shows did it sound like
I gotta Netflix for that but the move of
Disney plus aid yeah like he will I
realized every watched Godfather 1 & 2
this weekend and it's introduced to my
girlfriend and then I showed that I've
told this compilation of The Simpsons
parodies with the Godfather and then it
really hit me like oh man all the
episodes of The Simpsons are gonna be on
Disney Plus that's so that's like
awesome to me
demand and the new shows through the FX
but all the new shows on Disney Plus
that that really does excite me and she
was to be able to binge and all the
Disney films I haven't seen you know and
I'm excited you know although some of
them are really hard yeah they make it
that way by placing them into that damn
vault which they're now gonna start
doing with war with the Fox movies so
now I'm excited to see which Fox movies
are gonna be hard to get your hands on
first week I'm trying to watch Dark
Phoenix I'm trying to watch six men
three and I can't
it's a classic female Sopranos Dan Merle
he's got all those numbers man we have
not seen parasite I want to I heard it's
good cuz every top rewards here our
patreon are long requests so we're not
gonna watch any movies for the next
month yes we're just gonna all hate all
you guys for contributing
how dare you contribute it wrong you're
doing this altruistic act in the
complete wrong way the godmother that
would be a very different crime movie
that would be such a different crime
movie if women if women ran all the
crime families like there would still be
[ __ ] going down but I feel like it would
be way different one day where you're
gonna do that thing where people do a
ridiculous long ass livestream like like
us like those like 24 hours loads yes so
it's all just these yeah c'mon struggle
nations say he did like a three-day one
we didn't sleep some like that man that
guy's a machine he only got twenty
dollars in a super chick and he actually
lost a bunch of subscribers
there's a reaction news your reaction
keep getting notified with the same live
stream yes I'm so happy for everyone
Boehner I love this topic that is arisen
let's get a few more breaking Barbara
yes dude think about it I mean it
wouldn't it wouldn't be about a
character called Barbara it would be
what Skylar does to support Walt Jr now
that Walt is you know that all that so
she starts cooking her own drugs because
a single mother you know yeah yeah it
would be perfect
[Music]
what if patreon was 70% for two weeks I
don't know what that means
I mean like like we charge seventy
percent of what we normally do or like
we only get seventy percent of the
pledges or we're ha Benita and Shah wet
wow that's a stretch
[Music]
points for effort there you are welcome
for the live Todd gene gene I think you
had a question I missed it gene Jeter
that calendar still hasn't come in the
mail which is going to John by the way
oh yeah above my bed I'm gonna yeah on
the ceiling
John I think they're going to bring back
X 23 no no no no that continuity isn't
done with that world is over daphne keen
is on HBO now do you think we'll get
another joker film guys you gotta go
check out my movie fights episode where
I pitched my Joker to it's the most
recent movie fights episode and I feel
like I got the best one out there okay
okay you guys need matching afros what
I've no no John has the sexy long hair
and I got the funny curly hair that's
right
two very different responses ones like I
like your curls can I put my finger in
there and then girls just go to John ago
okay touch your hair it's so you can
just hear it's totally different town
human beings like to touch hair I've
noticed
I don't good you're not part of the
problem
everyone's like
my hair I'm like oh we're done have you
seen the brothers I don't want what is
back there I don't wanna meet somebody
that's touch your hair I wax my scalp
that's good you want to smooth as a cue
ball
what next movie will the world be stoked
for even I think even more so because of
the angst around us are gonna react a
more markiplier actually we have we're
probably going to be watching the high
school markiplier we're gonna
participate
why do you Bandersnatch when we get you
are comprised instead yes
guys there's no shame no Movember so
facial hair staying one day we should
just like to completely shave our facial
hair immediately be like oh come on
don't worry buy some Rogaine in stock
like woven beard you know beanies until
they come back in trying to branch out
with the sketches I have a few sketches
that I wrote that are not like what
we've done before VR cuz the other
sketches are like always Greg and John
you know this one was like essentially
our personalities but they're like
different kind of concepts that's not
exactly they're not just like to play
before a trailer or before a review
they're a little bit different but this
one I want to get like a team for the
other sketches we do would like us and
then a six days out full Cameron Hackett
want a branch from it a little bit more
that's that's what I'm trying to do more
short films on other people's stuff is
to get to know more people
I want to collab with ECOMOG struggle
nation do something there with them I
just try and branch out try branch out
I've seen so much no-shave November in
here but 0 no nut November what's up
with that guys well just hub recently
put out that millions of people failed
oh wow that's not worth trying it's not
worth trying it's a one of the biggest
lessons I ever learned from The Simpsons
one must be really oh
October thirty-first rolls around
they're like we're taking a Halloween
off we're preparing to make sure
everyone's watching porn we got a dump
money into advertising how can we get it
out there hey man they're they're taking
some strides in education how can you
prove if you don't nut for a month
how can handstand surveillance how can
you prove that dr. light visits I could
lie easily November with me read no
Trump no them no not November will yeah
because what if you have a wet dream
dude let's not get political keep
politics out of my live stream politics
out of everything keep politics out of
my political movies keep politics out of
my debate all right guys we're gonna
wrap this up
thank you guys so much for being here
thanks all the pitches this was a lot of
fun I appreciate all the gender swaps we
all contributed today literally you guys
create with us what we're creating
keep a lookout for something this week
you know we'll have videos much love
thank you everyone contribute to the
super chat by the way hold on before we
go I think we're gonna find the super
chat people John let's go max take that
window down so go up to the top bar yeah
I know what it's like to be you know I
know right
huh stressing that you're not finding
the right wing where's the Greg where's
the crack huh you should know this by
now Shawshank Redemption
[ __ ] wait a minute was there a female
Shawshank pitch here anyway when a girl
up Jordan
here you wanna switch really quick no
sorry for who I didn't think of me the
pin comment much love thank you guys be
safe remember remember the 5th of
November
see you guys